les responsables de cette entreprise ce poste
je quitte
mon
emploi de quatre ans aujourd'hui c'est moi sur le point
de quitter mon emploi dans l'entreprise
je suis allé chercher ma
lettre de démission c'est un je suis désolé
pour ta carte perdue et ça dit c'est moi
toi  'je suis en train de me perdre oh mon dieu mon patron est en
ligne en ce moment euh je vais envoyer un
message
attention tous les
associés et managers des acheteurs de walmart jimmy des
articles de sport joseph le caissier larry
du
centre de jardinage vous êtes tous des pervers
et j'espère que vous ne le faites pas'  ne parlez pas à vos
filles comme vous me parlez
tout au long de la journée, les managers étaient
encore plus grossiers que d'habitude
la journée ne se passait tout simplement pas bien sur le
chemin de la salle de pause j'ai vu quelques gars
qui m'avaient harcelé tout au long de l'année
et un  la moitié de ce que j'avais été là
et ils ont dit bonjour
et ils ont juste fait leur petite salutation
qu'ils font normalement aux jeunes filles
et puis ça a
encore plus intensifié mes émotions alors euh
j'étais comme si tu savais ce que je vais juste
arrêter
maintenant  j'arrête
je suis sorti
[Musique]
donc
ça va nous avons pleuré tous les deux
mais je l'ai fait et je lui ai dit la vérité sur
pourquoi j'arrête je suis juste heureux
je suis heureux de faire ça pour  moi-même, je ne
sais pas ce qui va arriver ensuite, j'ai peur
de mon [ __ ] d'esprit,
mais je suis heureux et je suis excité, j'espère que
cela inspire, encourage ou vous donne juste
une certaine motivation pour faire
quelque chose de similaire euh ou faire cette chose
que vous  ça fait longtemps que je pense à faire
[de la musique]
je travaille depuis que j'ai 14 ans.
donc
j'ai vu euh
l'
acte d'arrêter de fumer passer de oh c'est une si
mauvaise chose que tu dois trouver un travail dès que possible
deux
j'arrête je suis dans un meilleur endroit
je n'ai pas besoin de ça je
pense que ce qui pousse les gens à arrêter comme ça,
c'est le désir de travailler pour
eux-mêmes ou d'être
meilleur et de faire mieux pour eux-mêmes et
leur santé mentale et c'est en
quelque sorte pourquoi je  l'ai fait aussi j'allais à
l'école et je travaillais
et vous savez que je faisais tellement de
choses et ma santé mentale n'était pas
du tout une priorité
et je pense qu'en étant sur les réseaux sociaux, vous
verrez que la santé mentale est une priorité et
les gens ont l'air tellement plus heureux ils brillent
plus
je me sens tellement soulagé je me sens libre
non pas parce que je détestais le travail
c'est juste que je suis prêt pour un
style de vie différent j'ai l'impression que c'est le moment
parce qu'un jour
de plus de report cela signifie juste
un jour plus tard  je peux enfin consacrer 100
à l'entreprise de mes rêves
je suis nerveux
je pense que tout le monde doit
trouver
un endroit où ils sont
capables de démissionner avant de démissionner j'étais dans une
position où
je pouvais quitter mon travail je vivais en quelque sorte de
mon  des économies pendant quelques semaines
et je terminais l'école, donc
j'obtiendrais ma licence et commencerais à travailler et à
utiliser ma licence de cosmétologie
je pense que plus de gens vont commencer à
travailler pour eux-mêmes et à
se mettre en avant, ils veulent
avoir un
travail qui prend soin d'eux  mais
leur permet aussi de prendre soin d'eux-mêmes